maybe the American people have concluded
that impeachment is not promptly Rudy
Giuliani does not work for the US
government but as president Trump's
personal lawyer he appears at the center
of efforts to pressure Ukraine to
investigate Democrats House did national
security adviser John Bolton reportedly
called him a hand grenade and threatened
to blow up the administration Giuliani
made a name for himself going after
organized crime and public corruption as
a federal prosecutor in New York a job
that led to his election as mayor in
1994 but also to criticism he played for
the camera he was an extremely tough
prosecutor he went after Wall Streeters
he perp-walked them he went after the
mob he drove into Little Italy and
defied them so he was a tough aggressive
with an age of nastiness he was out to
get them and he got them
Giuliani rose to international
prominence in 2001 after the attacks of
September 11th earning the nickname
America's mayor but his ties to his
hometown and the law-enforcement
community have frayed since becoming one
of the controversial president's most
vocal defenders and Giuliani is now in
the sights of law enforcement himself
for his ties to these two Soviet born US
citizens charged with funneling foreign
money to u.s. politicians and lobbying
for the removal of the United States
Ambassador to the Ukraine Murray
Jovanovic President Trump called
Jovanovic bad news on that now infamous
call where he pressured the Ukrainian
president to investigate his political
rival former Vice President Joe Biden
and his son who had business dealings in
the country the US attorney for the
Southern District of New York the very
office where Rudy Giuliani rose to
prominence as a federal prosecutor is
handling the case of his associates it's
also the office that convicted Michael
Cohen the president's fixer of campaign
finance violations and
now is reportedly investigating Giuliani
himself can't wait to come back
Giuliani denies breaking the law since
he was working on behalf of the
president not a foreign agent I think he
shouldn't be underestimated I think he's
a tough guy
and I think some of his lashing out
acting out on the cable networks is is
kind of an act to distract to intimidate
and to again keep himself at the center
of the story which he's a very effective
at doing and so far he has refused to
cooperate with the impeachment inquiry
Kristen salumi al Jazeera New York